hi guys embroiled from simple on and
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become nai engineer so first off let's
ask the important question what is
artificial intelligence now artificial
intelligence is the ability of a
computer system to mimic human behavior
now this is the sort of intelligence
that's demonstrated by machines and this
is in contrast to natural intelligence
that's shown by humans as well as
animals so how does artificial
intelligence work firstly it learns from
past data
now whatever machines that are
artificially intelligent learn from
their actions which are positive or
negative now with this new information
the machine is able to make corrections
to itself so that these problems don't
resurface and make some adjustments to
handle new inputs and finally the
machine is able to perform human-like
tasks so who is an artificial
intelligence engineer an engineer builds
AI models using machine learning
algorithms and deep learning neural
networks to draw business insights now
these insights can be used to make
business decisions that affect the
entire organization not to mention they
also create weak or strong ai's
depending on what goal they want to
achieve now air engineers have a sound
understanding of programming software
engineering as well as data science they
use different tools and techniques so
that they can process data and they
develop as well as maintain AI systems
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of an AI engineer
firstly they need to develop test and
deploy AI models this can be done
through a number of different
programming algorithms like random
forests logistic regression linear
regression and so on they need to be
able to convert the machine learning
models into api's or application program
interfaces so that other applications
can use it they responsible for building
AI models from scratch and help the
different components of the organization
such as product managers and
stakeholders understand what they stand
to gain from the model they need to
build data ingestion and data
transformation infrastructure they need
to automate infrastructure that's used
by the data science team they need to be
able to perform statistical analysis and
tune the results so that the
organization can take better informed
decisions they need to set up as well as
manage AI development and product
infrastructure and they need to be good
at teamwork since they'll be
coordinating work with teams of data as
well as
analyst next up let's talk about the
skills required to become an AI engineer
first off programming skills now the
first skill required to become an
engineer is programming skills now for
you to become well-versed in AI it is
very important that you start learning
programming languages such as Python or
Java and C++ so that you're able to
build as well as implement so that
you'll be able to build as well as
implement models the second skill
required is linear algebra of
probability and statistics now to
understand as well as implement
different AI models such as hidden
Markov models nave based Gaussian
mixture models linear discriminant
analysis and so on you need to have
detailed knowledge of linear algebra
probability and statistics the third
skill required is knowledge about spark
and Big Data technologies now since a
engineers work with large volumes of
data which could be streaming or
real-time production level data
production level data in terabytes or
even petabytes they need to know about
spark and other Big Data technologies to
make sense of this along with Apache
spark you could also use other Big Data
technologies like Hadoop Cassandra and
MongoDB the next skill that you require
is to be well-versed with algorithms and
frameworks now understanding how machine
learning algorithms like linear
regression KNN nave base SVM and others
work will help you implement machine
learning models with ease also to build
AI models with unstructured data you
need to understand deep learning
algorithms like CNN which is the
convolutional neural network RN n which
is the recurrent neural network and GN
which is the generative into serial
network and so so that you can implement
it using a framework some of the
frameworks used in artificial
intelligence are PI toge Theano
tensorflow
and Caffe the final skill required to
become an engineer is communication and
problem-solving skills now you need to
be very good at communication so that
you are able to pitch your product and
idea to the stakeholders you should also
have excellent problem-solving skills to
resolve obstacles for decision making
and draw helpful business insights now
let's talk about an AI engineer salary
the average salary of an engineer is
hundred and eleven thousand dollars per
annum in the United States and rupees 13
lakhs per annum in India now let's talk
about the career
and rolls and artificial intelligence
since several industries around the
world use AI to some degree or the other
there has been an exponential growth in
the career opportunities within the
field of AI let's have a look at some of
these job roles first off we have AI
developer now these individuals work
closely with electrical engineers and
develop software to create artificially
intelligent robots next up we have AI
architect now these people work closely
with clients so that they can provide
business as well as system integration
services while at the same time creating
and maintaining the entire architecture
the next role we're going to talk about
is machine learning engineer now these
individuals build predictive models
using washed using vast volumes of data
have in-depth knowledge of machine
learning algorithms deep learning
algorithms and deep learning frameworks
next up we have data scientists now data
scientists collect clean analyze and
interpret large and complex datasets by
leveraging both machine learning and
predictive analytics and finally we have
bi developer or business intelligence
developer they're responsible for
designing modeling and analyzing complex
data to identify business as well as
market trends so how can simply learn
help you simply Leone has now tied up
with IBM and is offering the AI
engineers master's program this program
consists of a number of different
courses such as introduction to
artificial intelligence data science
with Python machine learning deep
learning fundamentals by IBM deep
learning with tensor flow and the AI
capstone project after completing this
course you'll get a certificate from
both IBM as well as simply learn which
is recognized across the world iBM is
the second largest predictive analysis
and machine learning solutions provider
globally a joint partnership with simply
learn and IBM introduces you to
integrated blended learning and making
you an expert in artificial intelligence
and data science the program
co-developed with IBM will make you
industry ready for artificial
intelligence as well as data science job
roles as benefit you get simply learn
job assist you performed capstone and 15
plus real-life projects and assistance
with 20 plus in-demand skills and tools
tools such as numpy Syfy Apache spark
Watson Kara's peyten R and much more
you also have certain other benefits
such as
access to exclusive forums which are
moderated by expert faculty and industry
thought leaders thousand two hundred
dollars worth of IBM cloud credits that
have been leveraged for hands-on
exposure access to IBM cloud platforms
such as IBM Watson which is ibm's own
supercomputer and other software for
24/7 practice access to digital badges
from IBM and of course the industry
recognized master certificate from
simply learned so if your dream is to
become an engineer I suggest you go on
to simply learn comm and get started on
your journey to getting certified and
getting ahead and with that we've
reached the end of this video I hope you
guys found this informative and helpful
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here